wer wie ich ein ziemlich großer fan von
star trek ist kennt den warp antrieb
schon 2010 haben forscher versucht eine
ähnliche antriebstechnik also ohne
treibstoff zu entwickeln jetzt gibt es
endlich neuigkeiten auf dem gebiet der
treibstoff losen antriebs forschung die
nasa hat einen antrieb getestet und
liefert nun erste ergebnisse welche dass
er vater jetzt bei klicks science
fiction
die nasa hat eine antriebstechnik
getestet die tatsächlich ganz ohne
treibstoff aus kommt dem sogenannten
canet antrieb von guido vetter der
antrieb erzeugt etwa eine kraft von 00
00 0 3 bis zu 0 0 0 0 0 5 minuten
das ist zwar fast nicht so im gegensatz
zu kräften von herkömmlichen raketen mit
über 30.000 minuten noch weniger als
nichts aber trotzdem ein enormer
fortschritt das von isaac newton
beschriebene wechselwirkung spitzel
prinzip wäre damit sogar außer kraft
gesetzt es besagt dass jede kraft eine
gleichgroße gegen kraft besitzt bei
einem antrieb ohne treibstoff wird es
keine kraft wie die des vorstoßes von
triebwerken und die gegenkraft den schub
nach oben geben
also gilt auch hier kein wechsel
wirkungsprinzip da der cani antrieb ohne
treibstoff arbeitet 2010 hat roger einen
ähnlichen antrieb vorgestellt den die m
drive oder ndrive doch vor fünf jahren
wurde das als irreal abgestempelt
chinesische forscher haben sich 2014 dem
projekt von scheuer etwas mehr gewidmet
und erstaunliche resultate dem
fachmagazin wired vermeldet hier
entwickelte antrieb könne 720 minuten
erzeugen die kraft würde vollkommen
ausreichen um einen satelliten mit
dieser antriebstechnik auszustatten
doch auch das hat kaum einer geglaubt
und der reaktion von 2010 und 2014
verhielt sich die nasa jetzt sehr sehr
vorsichtig bei der veröffentlichung der
forschungsergebnisse
sie nahmen kaum stellung zu der
detaillierten funktionsweise des
antriebs um keine skeptiker anzulocken
vielmehr veröffentlichten sie die
gemessenen ergebnisse allein die kraft
denkt sehr viel realistischer als die
von 720 minuten eine leistung von etwa
30 bis 50 minuten soll der kanne antrieb
aufbringen können diese leistung erzeugt
er durch mikrowellen physikalische
mikrowellen nicht die aus der küche sie
werden mit strom erzeugt also energie
wird schon benötigt könnte aber im
weltraum von der sonne kommen diese
wellen bewegen sich dann in einem
kleinen raum und in einem hin und her
und durch diese schnelle bewegung tritt
eine differenz zwischen dem sogenannten
strahlungsdruck innerhalb und außerhalb
des behältnisses auf die differenz soll
sich dann in form von einer kraft zeigen
die direkt in eine richtung freigesetzt
wird ohne dabei zwei kräfte kraft und
zugehörige gegenkraft wie bei einem
herkömmlichen antrieb zu erzeugen
vereinfacht ausgedrückt eine rakete mit
mit triebwerken die nach oben fliegen
kann ohne dabei kräfte die in richtung
boden zeigen beispielsweise in form von
verstößen oder luft strömt nutzen zu
müssen allerdings ist die kraft so
schwach dass sicher auf der erde kaum
irgendetwas bewegen würde
im weltraum ist das anders auch der
geringste dauerhafte schub kann über die
zeit sehr sehr große geschwindigkeiten
erzeugen
die vorteile des cani antrieb sind
gigantisch wenn das alles in größeren
dimensionen funktionieren würde könnte
man sich jede menge treibstoff sparen
die mikrowellen verlassen den behälter
natürlich nicht sie bewegen sich hin und
her und es gibt keinen verbrennen oder
verbrauch wie beim verbrennen von
treibstoffen wenn kein treibstoff mehr
benötigt wird spart man sich auch jede
menge gewicht das man in den weltraum
transportieren muss weshalb man so viel
treibstoff wiederum braucht es wäre
einfach ein bahnbrechender
technologischer physikalischer und
wissenschaftlicher schritt
eine kleine interessante info noch zu
der namensgebung der antriebstechnik die
die bedeutsamkeit der ergebnisse für die
nicht zur friesi caffyn unter euch
verdeutlichen kann sagte er habe sie
nach der schlacht von canet am 2 august
2012 116 von christus benannt der fällt
der hannibal gewann dort eine nahezu
unmögliche schlachte entgegnete den 16
regionen der römer mit einem
verhältnismäßig winzigen her
die 16 regionen sind die gesetze der
physik und das winzige her ist der cani
antrieb mit seinem feldherrn guido
vetter die neue technik könnte große
auswirkungen auf unsere umwelt haben und
nicht nur den treibstoffverbrauch der
raumfahrt deutlich senken drei der
beeindruckendsten erfindung gegen die
erderwärmung die unter anderem auch von
treibstoff nutzung negativ
beeinträchtigt wird findet ihr im video
hier oben so repp und zum block mit
täglichen wissenschaftlich news da kommt
ihr hier klicken
und was tut ihr denn so für die umwelt
wie spart ihr treibstoff um von a nach b
zu kommen beispielsweise mit
fahrgemeinschaften oder mit dem rad oder
ähnlichen was in euren ideen oder fragt
er öfter mal mit der bahn wenn sie nicht
gerade streiten lasst es uns in den
kommentaren wissen und bis dann bleibt
dran